I want to compliment you because thank
you you can't
[Laughter]
actually know that you're not even
curious what the compliment is I love
that no no interest you're just happy
it's a compliment yep no uh first of all
I've known you a long time uh always
consistently hilarious and then you did
this podcast way back in June of 2019 so
that's like a a long time even before
covid right and when you're on that
podcast you uh first of all you said you
had mixed feelings about being my friend
which is fine I've evolved you've
evolved yes the culture has evolved you
know during covet I sat around I did
some real soul searching and I said
maybe I am okay
I am existing in the world well so one
good thing came out of coven yeah
exactly uh no but on the uh on that
podcast you described this project that
you were working on and let me tell you
something everybody does that I mean you
came on and you said well I have this
dream which is you wanted to make this
movie and you wanted me uh make a
romantic comedy you know a gay romantic
rom-com yeah and uh and I thought okay
yeah but everybody says they've got a
project in mind that they're that's
going to be available someday in the
future if all goes well right here you
are now back on the podcast and you've
made the movie and you're promoting it
we made the movie it is coming out it's
not only coming out it's coming out at a
wide release made by Universal Studios
and thousands of theaters all over North
America and then strangely the world
right um except the countries that are
homophobic which is interesting wait
there won't be a Saudi Arabian premiere
of my gay rom-con
that's where I wanted to see it well I'm
sorry no I did I called the Cineplex
Odeon in Saudi Arabia and I have said I
want my ticket to Bros no the uh Billy
Eichner groundbreaking uh rom-com and
and they were kept saying it is not
available and I said that's that's a
glitch yep nope not a glitch that's just
uh how it is in certain parts of the
world
um but I'm happy that it's getting
released elsewhere where they don't hate
gay people
this is uh
this is but this is Landmark because
it's what's first of all I mean I want
to talk about the whole Arc of your
career because that's the kind of time
we have yeah I've booked six hours for
this I'm I'm gonna need more than that
but okay now I looked into it six hours
we'll cover it
um but I'm very excited for you because
your mission statement with this movie
was you said you're not interested in
depicting a version of queer life that
is palatable and I thought that is so
intriguing and fascinating to me talk
about that a little bit
well Bros which is the rom-com I have
coming out produced by Judah Apatow who
as all of you probably know has made
some of the funniest movies of the past
20 years bridesmaids and train wreck and
40 year old virgin and the list goes on
and on and I wrote it with Nick Stoller
and Nick directed it and he directed sir
uh Forgetting Sarah Marshall and
neighbors and you know these guys have a
great legacy of making great comedies
and Nick came to me uh back like five
years ago and said I want my next movie
to be a romantic comedy but I think it
would be cool if it was about a gay
couple but he acknowledged that he's not
gay and he asked me if I would ride it
with him and I could star in it if all
went well and he would direct it and I
said obviously yes a huge opportunity
one that I never saw coming in my life
um but the first thing I said to Nick is
even before I knew what the story of the
movie would be I said it has to be
authentic right you can't just make When
Harry Met Sally and think you can just
swap in to gay guys and have the story
play out the same way because it
wouldn't because you know yes there is a
lot of overlap and straight
relationships and gay relationships but
also it is a little different two men
together is different and there's a lot
of Comedy to be mined from that and also
a lot of you know uh poignant moments
and more thought-provoking moments and
it's just a different experience and I
think a lot of the lgbtq characters
we've seen and we're seeing way more
obviously than we used to especially in
streaming and in indie films and on the
internet of course and that's fantastic
that is a wonderful thing but so much of
it is done with an eye towards making us
these like cutesy two-dimensional
characters that really are nothing like
the actual gay men I know in my life
right or like me you know I watch a lot
of those shows and I a lot of those
sitcoms and even when they're very funny
I I think I don't know who those people
are you know I those are gay characters
designed to Not freak out straight
people right and I give straight people
a lot more credit than that I have a lot
of straight friends my show Billy on the
Street that I've done for years has a
huge fan base among straight people
Conan you are theoretically straight you
know you've always you know what I know
I go in and out I don't know what that
means everyone does now you find some
guys attractive I think can you totally
very openly about it I'm I'm very open
about yeah you know there are men where
I totally get it yeah and and like Brad
Pitt I just think like that's a really
good looking guy yeah you know so and
then I call him and it gets weird right
exactly and then you know you're well I
won't go there but um
I just did yeah I went there in my head
um but yeah I just thought I don't think
we're giving straight people enough
credit like funny is funny if you make a
really funny Judd Apatow movie that
happens to be about a gay couple then
straight people will love that and it's
not only funny it's kind of fascinating
yes because you're getting a peek into a
a world a culture of dating of Love of
sex that you think you might know but
you don't really know right and that was
really important to me I thought that
would be exciting and hilarious and I'm
happy to say so far you know when we do
early screenings of the movie A lot of
the audience is straight most of the
world is still straight uh and they love
it it's really funny it's just a [ __ ]
funny movie okay watch the language uh
why because I'm gay yes it's okay when
straight people swear I said Every curse
word on here
I think I'm pretty evolved but I still
believe yeah that gay people shouldn't
swear but straight people should okay hi
I'm Conan O'Brien and I just got cancer
welcome to Newsmax
the new home of Conan O'Brien the only
thing I've carved out is that swearing
is only for straight people
um no but is it possible that
uh the first wave of representation uh
in you know on sitcoms needed to be that
way that there needed to be an evolution
or there needed to be a first wave that
was more I want to just say
user-friendly yeah for people that you
know starting in like I don't know the
late 80s early 90s it just and this is
the way it kind of maybe had to lay out
where now we can get the point where you
Billy can make a movie that really is
telling it from a real point of view as
opposed to uh let's water this down yeah
I mean it makes sense there has been an
evolution and I'm really grateful that
you know when I went to Judd and Nick
and and I said that I wanted it to be
really authentic it's a Judd Apatow
movie his movies are like wild and
raunchy and fun and also very
heartwarming and uplifting and I just
said it once I wanted it to be all of
those things and there's no reason it
shouldn't be and they said yeah let's
just go for it like if it's honest it'll
be funny and relatable to everyone and
we're just in a weird industry that made
two movies about a talking Hedgehog
before they made one gay rom-com you
know what I mean so um I have my own
Hedgehog movie coming out no one worried
about whether or not Sonic the Hedgehog
was relatable
we made 50 movies about dinosaurs
extinct creatures
gay Rock
yeah
so the Velociraptor is going to rip off
the kid's throat and then shoot acid
into his eyes to Blind him no one ever
said it's Middle America ready for
dinosaurs
but that's the question that lingers
over a movie about like two actual human
beings right who walk the earth you know
meeting and falling in love and you know
driving each other crazy the way you
know people do